*singing*
♪Love! Oh Loaaaaghhhh
As a wise man once said, "I've been really trying baby
To hold back this feeling for SO long
And if you feel like I feel baby"
♪Let's get it on dun-bow adipa-dow-wow♪
You may be wondering to yourself, why oh why am I talking about love?
Well if you remember last year about this time
I made a video called "Who's Markiplier's Girlfriend?"
But in that video, I set out to do something that I
didn't accomplish in that video.
My original intention going into it was to find my YoutuberBoyfriend™.
And that didn't happen.
So I'm gonna go back on the internet and I'm gonna
Go on the only quiz-site that I know is capable of answering these
Hard hitting questions that lie deep within my own soul.
And Imma figure out
Who my true, TRUE YoutubeBoyfriend™ is.
And how will I know if they're good or not if I don't get matched up with them in a quiz?
That's the only way to know if a person is good or not, or worth your time
Right?
Alright, queue 'em up, knock 'em down-
Who's you-... Buttercream gang??
Your But- What? Wh- wait. What???
The fuck is a buttercream??
gang?
Like, I'm not making fun of the name, except that I'm absolutely making fun of the name
but what the fuck is a buttercream gang?!
That sounds horrible!
That sounds like a gang you meet on a dark alley and all they do is shove butter and cream in random places.
That is a fucking horror story.
I've never heard of that and frankly, I don't want to.
I gotta find- wait, I gotta find out...
I gotta find out my Buttercream Gang boyfriend.
"Find out who your Buttercream Gang boyfriend is"
"Joe Sugg", I know Joe Sugg, "Oli White", no
"Caspar Lee", I've heard the name.
"Joshua Pieters, Conor Maynard, Jack Maynard, Mikey-" I don't know any- I'm
I'm so out of the loop, I never know anything
Ahh, god, I don't know! I live in a bubble!
I live in a little bubble, *sputters* I live in a VAN!
I've got nothing to my name. I just want love
Let's see what the Buttercream Gang is gonna do to me
'cause frankly, I don't even know
"What do you spend most of your time doing?"
Agh, god. Sports -no. Traveling -no. Partying, DUH -no.
Spending time with friends -prft, no. If I had friends I still wouldn't do that.
Reading, aaahh. Something creative.... naah.
We'll go with, "Watching youtube, obviously"
"What type of music do you listen to?"
"Conor Maynard covers..." *whispers* Who's Conor Maynard??
I wanna google who Conor Maynard is, but I don't- I don't wanna spoil the results.
"Conor Maynard" Who is you? Who are you? Who- Who are YOU?
WHO ARE YOU?
I don't think screaming at you picture is gonna do anything for that but,
"Conor Maynard six pack"
Why is "Conor Maynard six pack"
Open up- damn. Oh, holding up some underwear... Why?
Okay, alright, so...
What I'm discerning from this picture is that, at some point in his musical act
His dick starts singing, which is why he's holding the microphone down by his crotch
And if that's true, I'm VERY impressed
I wanna listen to some Conor Maynard covers after that
'kay- OH No, "Ed Sheeran vibes"
No! I gotta stay true!
I gotta go with Co- I haven't heard a single cover, but I know they're magical!
I gotta do it! ED, I'M SORRY!
Alright, whatever, I don't care.
"Who's your favourite youtuber? Besides the Buttercream Gang of course."
God, the Buttercream Gang... That's so funny
"FooseyTube he's pretty cool"
"I don't watch anything bu- I don't watch ANYTHING, I don't watch ANYTHING besides the Buttercream Gang."
"Zoella, her tutorials are my favourite"
"Shane Dawson, I live for his conspiracies"
"James White, if he counts" Who's James white?
"Anyone that's part of team 10" *laughs*
I'm not on this list, so this is obviously bullshit
I watch nothing but the Buttercream Gang
I live for that sweet, creamy butter
*kissing sound*
I can't wait. I can't wait *kissing sound*
for that sweet *kissing sound*,
tender *kissing sound*,
delicious buttercream.
"What does a Friday night look for you?"
"Working sadly" *laughs* Yeah, that's- that's kinda true, that's very true
"Just hanging out with friends, it doesn't matter what we're doing"
Eh... Number 1, no friends.
Number 2, I don't hang out.
"Going out to dinner with family" Number 3, I don't have family here
"Packing for a trip to London, duh." Number 4, Last time I went to London I got the crazy flu
Like, I don't know if it's just all of London is bathed in flu, but I got some
and I brought it back, and I was sick for like two weeks
That's why last Christmas was all sick.
I'mmm looooaded, probably at Da Club
Catching up on my favorite sho--
Working. Sadly.
I'd like to think that's not a comma there, it's literally like
I'm hunched over at my computer on a Friday night, sadly working, weeping into my tears,
I mean... I'm makin' a Markiplier video, I gotta really get the tears goin for everything that i'm doing,
so I'mma....uh, seems pretty accurate.
What's your favorite show right now?
Glee will never die! ....isn't Glee over?
Teen Wolf... never seen it.
Dylan O'Brien is one piece of ass. That doesn't sound like a compliment,
Alright, Dylan O'Brien, are you a piece of ass?
AAAUUUGGGHHH
Yes? I don't know. Yes?
OHHHHHHH Maze Runno! Ohhh, the runno of mazes.That guy?
I can't choose because I've never watched any of these.
You're going on a date. Where do you go?
Uhhhpthbhth I dunno wheres the buddercrem geng wanna take me?
Hopefully Cracker Barrel because if there's one thing I know about Cracker Barrel's chicken and dumplings,
It's got a lotta budder, and there's probably some cream in there, of what type, I don't know, but it definitely is a possibility.
The Beach. Splashing around in the water is fun.
No! The beach suggests the ocean, and the ocean is death.
No! Nonuhngognghnough.....
Just walking around town, maybe a bit of d--*laughs* maybe a bit of dAnCiNG
Well, the only thing I pictured there was that, like, we were walking around town and it was just like--
"Heyyyy...do ya like jazzzz?" *breaks up laughing*
Can't go wrong with some Italian food and a movie...
You CAN go wrong. For example....
*dramatic music with complicated math equations flying across the screen*
*music suddenly stops*
GOAHH-G-I GOT IT you're trying to Lady and Tramp some spaghetti together but you accidentally get it wrapped around your own necks
But you're so intensely focused on the sucking of noodle to each other, that you accidentally cinch it too tight,
CUT OFF EACH OTHER'S HEADS.
Death by noodle.
That's how Italian can go wrong.
Pizza and Netflix. Cuddling is better than anything.
I don't.. I don't think your gonna be cuddling with the Buttercream Gang!
He can pick, I'm too indecisive. A long car ride, conversations are always best.
Kill me *laughs*
I'm gonna go with death by Italian food, Imma pick that one.
Let's see. Who's your style icon?
Who is that?
Someone a lot more old fashioned, like Marilyn.
...Monroe???
Does Harry Styles count?
Mmmm...
Veronica Lodge. Always. I don't know who that is.
Ariana Grande, she always has the cutest hair looks... Ok.
I wear what I want; I don't really look up to anyone for fashion advice
and that's not a statement I'm ma-- that's not like I'M DRAWINGA LINE IN THE SAND
I'M SO GOOD BECAUSE I DON'T DO THAT THING
I'm just like--- uh, look at what I'm wearing *cries* I just-- I grabbed this outta my closet, not because I was like "Oh this'll be fun on camera"
'Cause it's the first thing my hand touched, and I was like "I can't make another choice, ah whoops, oh well" That's me.
Describe yourself the best you can.
Genuine, down to earth, and loving.
PTHBTHBTH.
Adventurous, quiet, sweet.
N O
Adrenaline junkie, honest, humorous.
FUCK THAT
Fearless, loud, stylish.
2 of the 3, 2 of the 3 of those.
Bubbly, open minded, and creative.
These are none of me.
Where is the brash, annoying, and stupid? *laughs*  (aww mark nooo)
Alright, i'll go fearless, loud, and 𝓼𝓽𝔂𝓵𝓲𝓼𝓱 cuz, frankly...look...look at me.
I'm sorry I did that...
What's your favorite subject? Math or science. I can never choose! They're all so good! I'm not in school anymore.
History, I love learning about the past. Like when I was in school, that was so long ago, right!
Art, always. Noo!
Aaaahhh, imma go with music, cuz I was a band nerd. I played trumpet for years, all through school.
What's your go-to hairdo?
-PFFT-
Ya want to know Markiplier's secret style tips for hair...
...Care?
I wake up, dip into my cream butter
I dip into my- my vat of butter cream
I scoop that and kinda mush it until
It squeezes out between my hands
And then I kinda like just-
I don't really like style it
Like run it through my hair
I just kinda like splat it on top
And then as I go through the day
That starts to melt naturally
And create these flowing curls of pure grease
And- and frankly- and frankly
You can't pay for looks this good.
So that's- yeah that's- that's what I do.
I'm gonna go with natural because
This is no planning.
Nothing I do is ever planned.
Last one: Pick your fate.
Wha?
Puppy? Hm? Moist? Eugh
Moist?
Marcus But- Who is Marcus Butler?!
WHO ARE YOU? WHO ARE YOU? WHO ARE YOU?
WHO ARE YOU?
I don't know who Marcus Butler is but I- I
Got so off topic that I have no idea;
I'm gonna pick moist
Cuz I hate myself
Oli- WHO ARE YOU?
Congratulations, you have gotten the family oriented
Oli White. Hopefully he'll love you just as much
as he loves James. WHO IS JAMES?
WHO'S OLI WHITE?
I wanna love you, Oli White!
You! Hey! How's it going?!
My name is Markiplier!
*gibberish* AH! It's Markiplier! Oh shit dude
G-g-get the Buttercream gang!
*laughs* This man's business here!
Oh shi- oh fuck a book?
Wait, hang on
*alarm sounds*
(Video: Tech Cupboard)
(Video: I don't even have a TV anymore!)
(Video: My photos as a kid, just, you know, great memories.)
(Video: Unlike this one of-)
Oh, he's such an emotional guy!
(Video: moving out of my apartment)
(Video: Look! Even in here! Look at my cupboards!)
Not your cupboards!
(Video: That's meant to be the fun games cupboard.)
AUGH
(video: There is no fun in there anymore)
OH GOD
(Video: We don't even have Alexa anymore, like,)
(Video: How am I meant to turn on the lights? Like, Alexa turn on the lights)
WHO HURT YOU OLI
I'LL KILL EM, I'LL BEAT 'EM TO DEATH WITH
MY DIAMOND PLAY BUTTON
I'LL WACK 'EM RIGHT UPSIDE THE SKULL
I'LL GIVE 'EM THE OLD ONE FOR
He's got a v- He's got a van!
(Video: It's in the van)
He's got a VAN!
HE'S GOT A VAN!
He's got a van- I've got a van.
Ahahaha, hehehehehe
Alright, okay, I can live with that
I can live with- I can- I can live with that
I don't know who else is in the Buttercream gang
And I don't know who else the.. Buttercream.. gang is about
There's so many like... teams
That are assembling now on Youtube
And I have no idea when that kind of started
*laughs* I have no idea
I-it's interesting, it's a fascinating thing
I'm not knocking it any way
I just think the Buttercream gang is a funny name
And I would like to know the history of why it's called that
But anyway!
Oli White is my YoutuberBoyfriend™.
I think I've found true love.
Or, the most close substitution which is
a long distance relationship where Oli White doesn't
actually know who I am and I kinda
talk about him weird on the internet
*inhales*
JUST LIKE ALL MY OTHER RELATIONSHIPS *gibberish*
So anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching
If you wanna see more stuff like this, lemme know
down in the comments below
If you know more about all these teams and who
The Buttercream gang is;
Fill me in in the comments below as well.
And as always; I will see you, in the next video.
Buh-bye!